(beeps)
(light upbeat music)
- I wanted to sort of pitch
or present the work today
in the context of the effects of stress
because of the high
burden that mental illness
has on young people.
That is as many as 40%
of young people today
experience a mental illness.
The majority of these are
related to anxiety and stress.
And if we don't treat
these early, they can go on
to lead to chronic
illness, both psychiatric
as well as physical illness.
So the questions that we've been asking
in our laboratory over the years
is how are these early life experiences
impacting emotional
well-being and the underlying
brain circuitry involved
in that well-being?
And ultimately, what we need to do is
to use this information
so that we can facilitate
and enhance healthy brain development
and also, of course,
well-being of young people,
which is then gonna be
well-being of our society.
But if we first take
just a simplistic look
at all the changes that are happening
in post-natal development,
what you'll see is
that there is dramatic changes
just in the number of
synapses throughout the brain
that develop regionally.
So we see a proliferation
and a subsequent pruning
of these connections.
Simultaneously, their
changes in nerve chemicals
and neurotrophins that
are absolutely essential
to development and learning.
And with all these regional
changes, it is co-occurring
with increased myelination
throughout the brain,
which is making the connections stronger.
So we've been focused on
all these dynamic changes
and trying to understand
with just one picture
using human imaging and
focusing on one circuitry
that's really important for our ability
to process emotional information.
So emotion regulatory and
emotional reactive processes.
And during this time, during
childhood and adolescence
there are major changes in this circuitry,
and we think that they
will, are one pathway
for us to seeing how
early life experiences
are reflected in them and how
this continued development
may also be a window
of plasticity of sorts
where we may have the biggest change.
Now, in human studies, one of the ways
that we try to look at
this, at these circuitries
in the behaving human
brain non-invasively,
is to use simple stimulator
cues that we present.
So here are, here's an example of a cue
with emotional information.
We examine how these cues
impact both brain and behavior.
These cues can be positive, smiling faces,
or negative, or they can be neutral.
But what we see is even if you are
in the laboratory performing this task,
if we ask you just to press a button
whenever you saw one of these cues,
you would be significantly
longer in detecting
a threat cue, a fearful
cue, than you would be
to a neutral or happy as you see here.
So we have a longer latency there.
It's adaptive when we see cues
that have some uncertainty or ambiguity.
I don't think for a minute
when I present this cue to you
that you are threatened by that.
However, we learn over a lifetime
when we see cues like this
that there might be potential danger,
and what's very important
for us to understand
is in this context, is it a threat?
So if a bear were to come into the room,
I might have an emotional response.
But the circuitry is
important if I saw a bear
in a zoo to know that that
bear, in that situation,
I would be safe because they
were behind a cage or wire.
So now, if we look at these responses
in this change in our responses
depending on the potential
threat of information in our environment,
if we open up the brain and look inside,
the areas that tend to
be related to that delay
in our approach behavior
in such situations
involve the amygdala and
the prefrontal cortex.
And hopefully, what you
note from this slide
is that the amygdala,
the more active it is,
the slower you are to respond.
The amygdala is very
important in picking up
the emotional significance of
information in the environment
and has been associated
with emotional reactivity.
In contrast, the prefrontal cortex,
which has direct projections
to the amygdala based
on elegant animal work and
more recent human work,
that area is less active when
you're really slow to respond.
And the more active it
is the quicker you are.
That is, you see a potential threat.
You are able to understand
in this particular situation
with repeated presentations of it.
Get over yourself.
Alright, already.
Nothing's gonna happen to you.
Now, I've just made a sort
of claim that over time,
nothing's gonna happen to you.
Well, let's look at that in the brain
and what systems are
absolutely essential for that.
What's important when we look at
with those repeated presentations
how well you habituate to these cues
is this inverse coupling
between the prefrontal cortex
and the amygdala in this circuitry.
And this inverse coupling
or negative connectivity
seems to be changing radically
from childhood to adolescence.
And it is when you are not
able to habituate that response
that is associated with
heightened anxieties,
so I just want you to focus
on this quadrant for a moment.
And basically, if you
look over at the Y axis,
that's amygdala habituation,
and it's a negative score.
That means not only was there
not a change in how active
the amygdala was to these
cues but that it was actually
sensitized and it was
increasing over the course
of the experiment.
And that's related to the highest level
of self-reported trait anxiety.
Now, some of these
pictures had a lot of data,
and I think data slides and pictures
are worth 100 or 1,000 words,
but movies might tell a simpler story.
So this is an example of
an individual who reports
low anxiety, and they're being presented
with these cues of potential threat.
So you'll see, there's bilateral activity
in the amygdala with
repeated presentations,
but then, it's like the
system begins to return
to baseline, and it turns blue.
That represents from the increase
going back down to baseline.
In contrast, when we look at an individual
with high anxiety, we
basically see a similar pattern
at first with this bilateral
activation of the amygdala,
but then, it stays up and
it stays up and it stays up.
And it doesn't return to baseline.
So it's that vigilant state
of that anticipation of threat
and an uncertainty of what
these cues potentially mean.
So, two different paths
that we have taken in trying
to understand these two very
different neurosignatures here
is to look at differences
in genetic factors
that may explain this, but in the interest
of the symposium today,
also, in the environment
or experiences that we have.
So how does early life stress impact
the development of the circuitry?
And we have used really an extreme example
of early life stress.
It is an unfortunate but
a natural occurring one.
And that is children who
grow up in the orphanage.
Now, in the orphanage experience,
all the orphanages vary.
But there's always gonna be
some fragmented caregiving
because of the high
ratio of so many children
to a single caregiver.
So what we've been interested in is
as these children are adopted to families
in the United States, we've
been trying to understand
how this disregulation of
their needs not being met,
how there's not attunement
in the child's needs
with what a caregiver can
actually provide to them,
how that impacts their
ability to regulate self.
But particularly today, I'll talk
about how to regulate emotion.
So again, we use these simple cues,
and we ask children who have been adopted
from the orphanages as
well as a comparison group
who have not been adopted,
who live in the United States.
They all have moved.
The adopted children have been
here for at least two years
to make sure they get acclimated
to their new home and their
new culture and environment.
And what we do is we present
these cues of potential threat.
But in the task we tell
'em, you know, ignore these.
Try not to pay attention to them.
And you find, in the
situations in which you have
these cues relative to situations
where you present a smiling face,
that the adopted children are much slower
in anticipation of one of them occurring.
So even if it's a neutral
face on the screen,
if they know they're about
to see a threatening face,
they're really hesitant to respond.
But if it's to a happy
face or a smiling face,
you don't see a difference
between the two groups.
Now, this is paralleled in the brain
by enhanced activity in the amygdala.
And that's shown here on
the left and the right side.
But what I think is important
about these findings
if first, this is greater
activity in the children
who were adopted from orphanages abroad
relative to the comparison group.
The area in blue is actually more active
in the comparison group.
This is a part of the
brain that's important
for attention regulation
and emotion regulation.
So one is being able to regulate
their emotions and ignore.
And the other is quite
reactive, that group.
But more importantly, when
you see images like this,
and you have these neurosignatures,
it is how does that relate
to their actual behavior
when you get them outside
of the scanner environment
or the laboratory.
And so, we measured how the behavior
between caregivers and
their adopted children
when they had been separated briefly
and then, they were reunited.
And we looked at the amount of eye contact
they had with their caregiver
when they were reunited.
And basically, we see that the
more active the amygdala was
the less eye contact they
had with the caregiver.
Also, the less eye gaze they
actually held on the faces
that they were presented in
the experiment as well, too.
Now, when we have natural
occurring experiments
such as this, we don't really have control
on preexisting conditions
that may be there,
genetic or environmental.
So we've actually turned
to use mouse models
to try to see if we can
control for the genetic
and environmental confounds
that might otherwise explain
what we're seeing.
And so we borrowed paradigms
that have been developed
by individuals like Regina Sullivan at NYU
and also Tallie Baram at UC Irvine
to, and do sort of a fragmented caregiving
of a dam to her pups.
And so I wanted to show you those movies.
On the top is a dam where we've taken away
the nesting material.
She has a little bit but not sufficient,
so she is running around,
oh, this is not in real time.
(laughs)
(audience laughs)
She's a little bit slower than that.
So basically, I don't even know
if you can see the control dam.
So she has all the nesting
material she needs.
And she's spending the
majority of her time
grooming and feeding, nursing her pups.
But you can see the mother
above is trying to pull together
the nesting material
and sometimes her pups
over to her corner for the nest.
So basically, you're
seeing this fragmented care
because she can't attend to her pups
when she's doing other things,
which we thought might,
in the slightest way,
mimic some of the fragmented
care we see in the orphanages.
And if you look within a two hour period,
you see a significant
difference in the amount of time
that the dam is spending with her litter
relative to controls.
But quite frankly, if you
look across a 24 hour period,
they're spending almost as much
time with physical contact,
but it's very fragmented in that contact.
So there's not that attunement
between the caregiver
and the pup.
So then, if we look at
their ability to regulate
their emotions, not the
dam, but now her offspring
who've been given this fragmented care,
basically, what we see
is a paradigm in which
we've trained them that a
nozzle will lead to them
having access to condensed milk.
And mice love condensed milk.
And so we put that nozzle in a novel cage
with a bright light where there's
potential threat for mice.
And we see that when we put it there,
there's a difference between those mice
that grew up with the stress dam relative
to the mice whose dam, their
mother, was not stressed.
And you don't see any difference in terms
of how quickly they move to
the nozzle in their home cage.
And then if we look at
the brain using C-Fos
activity as an index, we see
heightened amygdala activity
in this group relative to the controls.
And so this gives us a bit more confidence
that what we're seeing in the human data
that I presented is not as much associated
with maybe preexisting conditions as it is
with the early life stress
because these parallel
quite nicely.
Now, with the mice,
unlike our human children
who are usually adopted by super parents,
if you do nothing after that, you see
that there's persistent affects
of that early life stress
so that they're still showing
heightened amygdala reactivity
in adulthood even though
there's continued development
of the circuitry.
Now this persistent effect in these mice
is somewhat reminiscent
of work that Nim Tottenham
has done at Columbia in
collaboration with Dylan Gee
whose now a colleague of
mine at Yale University.
And she's actually shown that if you look
at this frontolimbic
circuitry, that there may,
there appears to be something similar
to a premature closing
of a sensitive period
of neurodevelopment of this circuit
such that if you just
look at healthy children,
what I described before,
there are drastic,
significant changes from coupling
between the prefrontal
cortex, and it becomes inverse
or negatively related in adolescence.
What we see in children who
have grown up in the orphanage
is you're already seeing
those changes early.
And so now, Nim is
trying to follow and see
just how rigid does
that make the individual
when they go through adolescence,
which is an even more
stressful time of life
in meeting so many challenges.
And I just want to end
with one more study,
an area of work that Dr.
Tottenham is following up on,
and that is showing how
important the caregiver is.
And so, in these experiments,
where we're showing
these very simple stimuli in the scanner
while we're taking pictures of the brain
and watching how they perform games,
if you simply put a picture
of the face of the caregiver
along the screen where
they're performing the task,
and you can counter-balance
that with a face of a stranger,
she sees that that's associated
with decreased activity
in the amygdala, so it's a
decrease in that emotional
reactivity just by having that
parental cue present there.
And also, there is an increase
in the inverse coupling
with the prefrontal cortex that is typical
more of adulthood, but
we're seeing the parent
has that ability to regulate.
So I hope what I've shown you
or illustrated is just one
small set of experiments
that are being performed
where we can show that early life stress
can lead to persistent
changes in brain and behavior,
particularly in terms
of emotional capacities.
And it highlights, too,
this last bit of work,
the importance of having
very early interventions
and also, the importance of the caregiver
in helping to develop a healthy brain.
And also, in terms of enhancing
emotional well-being now
and hopefully, for that individual.
So I just want to end by
thanking so many individuals
who have come through my
laboratory over the years,
the majority of them fellows
who are stellar stars now.
And to also thank you for your attention.
- I'm really delighted
to be able to participate
in this wonderful symposium.
What I would like to tell you
today is one particular aspect
that is absolutely essential
for a normal brain development.
And that is to have proper parenting.
We've heard from the wonderful talk
from BJ Casey right
before me how important
proper nurturing from caregivers
is for normal mental health
of the infant that then become adult.
And so the question we've
been very interested in is
what makes a parent a parent?
If you think about
parenting involve one, two,
sometime multiple adults
that take care of an infant.
The relationship is
completely asymmetrical.
There is really a very helpless individual
that requires a lot, a lot of care
for a very, very long time.
And so what makes parents be parents?
It's a, I think, a very
interesting behavior,
long-term behavior, that has
a lot of emotional components.
And so this is a behavior
also that is displayed
by many animal species.
It is absolutely essential
for the development of
and the survival of the species.
So the idea is that there
maybe some genetically
pre-programmed neurocircuit in the brain,
and what we are interested
in is really trying
to understand the neural basis.
What are the specific
neurons that are involved
in the control of parenting behavior,
in the display of parenting behavior?
And when is it that this
behavior actually goes wrong?
And there are a number of circumstances
in which the behavior goes wrong.
One, this is one of, I
think, one of the most
outstanding, really impressive,
or very surprising slide
related to mental illness.
That's the number of
psychiatric hospitalization
after childbirth.
You can see right at
the time of childbirth
this enormous peak in
psychiatric hospitalization
of women, and this are
patients that suffer
from post-partum psychosis.
This is very quite rare.
It requires hospitalization
because these women
have obsessive thought
about harming their child,
their children, and
therefore, they require
very intensive care.
These very way less severe from,
which is post-partum depression
that affect 10 to 20%
of mother and 5 to 10%
of fathers in the US.
And this also comes right
after birth and result
in a inability to emotionally
connect with children
and in effect impaired parenting.
Now, there are quite a
number of risk factors:
stress, life circumstances,
prior depression,
and sensitivity to hormone changes.
As it turns out, right at
birth, there's an enormous
change of hormonal levels
in the young mother.
You can see here progesterone,
estrogen, oxytocin,
prolactin is really an
enormous and very sudden drop
in hormone level.
Some people call these hormonal cows,
and women, in particular,
that are sensitive
to these hormone fluctuation
have really a difficulty
in coping with those changes.
So how do we understand the
positive and the negative
regulation of parental behavior?
Well, let's turn to animals.
So in animals and human as
well, the primary caregiver
is usually the mother, and in animals,
and in mammals in particular,
this makes a lot of sense
because in mammals, the mother
nurture the fetus, the embryo,
in utero for a long period
of time an animal is
involved in lactation,
so really involve enormous
maternal resources
in nurturing the infant and
therefore it makes sense
that mom continued to nurture the infant
through parental behavior.
What about males?
Well, in most mammalian
species, a very large subset
of mammalian species, the males
actually attack the infant.
Attack them sometime, or very
often actually kill them.
And this infanticidal behavior
has been widely observed
in many animal species.
And it is thought that this is actually
an evolutionary-driven
aggressive behavior of the males
in order to gain access to the females
that are not accessible
when they are nurturing
their own infant.
And interestingly, this is
a behavior that is absent
in monogamous species
in which both the male
and the female are nurturing their infant
and therefore, there is not this conflict
of access of the male to the female.
Now, infant neglect and
aggression is also occasionally
displayed by stressed female.
This is seen in animals
as well as I mentioned
in post-partum depression
and psychosis in human.
Now, we're not working with human.
We're not working with primates.
We're working with mice, and in mice,
there is as in this animal
species I mentioned,
a very clear sexual dimorphism
in the behavior of animal,
male and female towards infants.
Females even virgin females or
sexual inexperienced female,
spontaneously take care of infants.
They will build a nest.
They will lick and groom
the pups, retrieve them
to the nest and huddle around the infants.
Virgin males in contrast will
spontaneously attack infants,
wound them, and kill them
through infanticidal behavior.
So very different set of behavior.
However, males are not
always infanticidal,
and in fact, strikingly, males
after mating with the female,
are no longer infanticidal.
And the video I would
like to show you here
is from, if you wish, a
certified infanticidal male.
This male attacked infants
three weeks earlier,
and then, we had that
male mating with a female.
And then, we're testing the behavior
of this male now with these pups.
And, as you can see, the
male has built a nest,
and now, is retrieving
these pups one by one,
and I should mention by the
way that these are not the pups
of that particular male.
This behavior will be
displayed towards any infant
that is, to which they are exposed.
So all the pups are now
collected to the nest,
and as you see, this is a really good dad.
(audience laughs)
He is checking that he has
not forgotten any pups.
Okay.
Nobody left.
Good.
(audience laughs)
Let's go back to the nest and
then take care of the pups.
So this is a really
fascinating switch in behavior
that really indicate that
even in infanticidal males
there's the ability for
these males to be parental.
So how is this happening?
Well, evolutionary
speaking, this is actually
not that surprising because
if you look at virile
animal species, insects,
fish, amphibians, reptiles,
birds, and mammals, they are
species in which the female
is always the one handling the progeny.
You can see the little eggs here
and little larvae over here.
He's a tadpole on the back of that frog.
But very similar species,
genetically very similar,
show animal in which
there's bi-parental care,
so both the male and the
female handle the nurturing
of the progeny, and similarly,
also very similar species
genetically have the male
that exclusively takes
care of the progeny.
For example, this beetle here
with the little eggs here
or this male amphibian with a tadpole
or here this fascinating
monkey, the Titi monkey,
in which the male is actually
providing exclusive care
of the infant.
So what's happening here?
Well, in mice, what's happening is
that there's a dominant male
that mates with the female
and the female have a communal nest.
These male is always parental.
However, subordinate males
that do not have access
to the female, are
infanticidal will attempt
to attack the male,
kill the pups, and that,
in turn, enable them
to mate with the female
and at that time, they become parental.
Now from a neuroscience standpoint,
this is fascinating because what it shows
is that the brain has
actually two types of circuit.
One driving infanticidal
behavior that is displayed
by virgin males and one that
drives parenting behavior
that is displayed by females and fathers.
So the question we are very interested in
is what are these neurons
that control parenting
and infanticidal behavior?
And I would like to tell you today is
how are we able to identify neurons
that are necessary and sufficient to drive
parenting behavior both
in males and in females?
And so, what we use is a
way to identify molecularly
neurons that are active
during the certain behavior.
And the idea is that when a neuron
is firing action potential,
they're also changing
their gene expression.
And in particular, they
turn on a particular gene,
a transcription factor called C-Fos.
And so if we have a female or
a male interacting with pups,
then neurons that are involved
in parenting will fire
and therefore, they will
express this gene C-Fos.
So if we look at the
brain of parenting animal,
both males and female,
compared to infanticidal male,
we find that there is a
sub-population of neurons
in one particular area of the brain
in the hypothalamus, an area
called the medial preoptic area
in which you see this very
dense collection of neurons
that express this gene C-Fos
after the animal has interacted
with pups, both males and females.
So this is very interesting.
It's actually not that
surprising because already
in the 50s, 60s, 70s, a number of groups
through lesion experiment have
shown that maternal behavior
requires the function of
the medial preoptic area.
But what we really would like to know
is which precisely, what
precisely are the nature,
the identity, of these neurons
that are C-fos positive?
And in fact, this area,
the medial preoptic area,
fulfill a lot of functions.
It's involved in mating
behavior, thermal sensation.
All sort of other functions
than just parenting.
So knowing precisely and
specifically which other neurons
that express C-Fos is something
that we really need to know
if we want to understand the
control of parenting behavior.
So we tested the number
of candidate genes,
and we found to our delight
one particular gene,
the gene that in code for
the neuropeptide galanin
has been very nicely
co-expressed with C-Fos
when the animal are parenting.
So interestingly, this,
the number of galanin cells
in the medial preoptic
area is identical in males
and females in virgin
males and in virgin male
and mothers and father.
In other word, these neurons are there
in the male and the
female brain irrespective
of whether these neurons
are parenting or not.
Now, galanin is a peptide
expressed in many different areas.
It has been involved in
many different functions
such as nociception, sleep,
thermoregulation, et cetera.
So we don't know whether
galanin has any role to do,
to play in parenting
behavior, but the fact
that we know one genetic
marker gives us genetic tools.
In other words, we're
able to use a genetic line
that express this enzyme called cre.
Think about the scissor
if you wish that enable
to activate specific molecular tool
to manipulate the activity of neurons.
And so the experiments that we've done
is to inject a conditional
toxin into the preoptic area
of the galanin cre
mouse, and what this does
is that it enable us to kill specifically
this galanin neuron present
in the medial preoptic area.
No other neurons outside of
the brain or within the MPOA.
Nothing else than the specific
galanin expressing cells
are affected.
What's happening when we test the behavior
of females and fathers when
we kill galanin neurons
in the medial preoptic area.
The affect is very striking.
The ablation of these MPOA galanin neurons
entirely abolishes both
maternal and paternal behavior.
And actually, elicits infanticide.
So there seem to be a
role of these neurons,
not only in driving parental behavior
but actually inhibiting
infant mediated aggression.
Now, we try the other experiment,
a sufficiency experiment,
which is if we now take an aggressive male
and activate artificially galanin neurons
in these infanticidal
males, what's happening?
What's happening, and we
performed this experiment
using a technique called optogenetics
that enable to express a
light-activated channel
in the neurons and then
using an optic fiber
to activate these cells, and what we found
when we shine light and
activate these galanin neurons
is that infanticidal male
now are longer infanticidal
and instead display paternal behavior.
So what it shows is that
this specific population
of neurons are both
necessary and sufficient
for the control of parental behavior
in both males and females.
Now, the parental behavior
is a complex behavior,
and what we'd like to do
now is really to understand
this behavior in mechanistic terms.
So these neurons as we've seen
are able to control parenting.
Parenting means a lot of
things: grooming, licking,
crouching, retrieving, nest building,
and then inhibiting infanticidal behavior.
But these neurons do all of
this according, obviously,
to the presence of an infant but also,
according to the physiological state.
Male, for example, will
either trigger this behavior
or not trigger this behavior according
to whether they are fathers or not.
And so, what we would
like to understand is
how are all these different
displays being performed
and what is the role of this environment
in the activity of these neurons?
And the first set of
experiment that we've done
is really tried to understand
whether these galanin neurons
really are involved in
all these different part
of parenting.
And so, the experiment that
I'm gonna show you here
is what is called bulk
imaging or volume imaging
of these galanin neurons.
The idea is that these
neurons now are expressing
genetically encoded
indicator of neural activity.
So these neurons are now
gonna emit fluorescence
when they are active and
only in this particular area.
And when we have an optic
prompt that enable to visualize
the intensity of the signal.
And so it's called bulk imaging
because we don't have cellular resolution.
In other words, we're
looking at the activity
of all these neurons together.
And so what you see here is a female
and here a bunch of pups over there.
And the animal has an optic fiber here
and what you can see here
is the level of calcium.
And as the female approaches the pups,
you can see the level of calcium going up.
And she's licking the pups,
and indeed the level
of calcium stays high.
And then as she brings
the pup to the nest,
and start licking the pup,
then the level of calcium
is really going up the roof.
Interestingly, we found
that all of the pups
composing parental behavior
involved this galanin neuron.
So that's quite interesting.
Now, I'm gonna show you another video
in which this female
here has a very similar
type of behavior as you can see.
She's grooming something, licking,
and then, she's gonna bring
that thing to the nest
exactly as she has done with the pups,
but as you can see here, the level
of C level is completely flat.
What's happening?
Well, although the
behavior looks very much
like parenting behavior, actually,
she's handling a fish
cracker, so that's not.
(audience laughs)
And in these circumstances,
galanin neurons
are totally silent.
Again, although the behavior
looks exactly the same,
what's happening in the
brain, the significance
of this behavior is completely different
and involved in very
different parts of the brain.
So, in summary, we started by the idea
that parenting is an essential behavior
and that in different species
it's displayed differently
by males, by females, sometimes both,
and that we were really
interested in going
to the cellular and molecular
basis of this behavior.
And we saw in this really
interesting system in a mouse
in which animal are or not parenting,
and we found this
fascinating immunocell type,
this MPOA galanin neurons
that now really give us entry
into how parenting behaviors control.
What are the different
regulations of these neurons?
What are their sets of projection?
What type of input do they receive,
and how all of these changes
in both during development
in males and females and
during mental illness.
And I would to thank the people,
the wonderful collaborator
in my lab who've performed this work.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- I tend to get unsolicited feedback,
such so that should be a very short talk.
(audience laughs)
Isn't that a kind of
contradiction of terms?
You mean they found one?
(audience laughs)
And there's like a book a month
that sort of piles on in
these unflattering portrayals.
The Primal Teen, that's
actually not too bad,
but Mom, I Hate You: Get Out of My Life,
but First, Drop Cheryl
and I Off At the Mall,
Now, I Know Why Tigers Eat Their Young,
or right to the point,
Yes, Your Teen is Crazy.
But with the technologies such as
magnetic resonance imaging,
we can for the first time
look under the hood at
the living growing brain.
And what we've found is that
not only do teens have brains,
(audience laughs)
but they're good brains.
They're as they should be.
They're not broken.
And I'd go so far as to
say if they weren't the way
that they are, we wouldn't even be here.
Evidence from that comes from
a kind of unlikely source
that I'll get to in a minute.
So the teen brain's different
than the brain of a child.
It's different than the brain of an adult.
It's not just halfway between.
It's, you know, kind of
its own distinct entity,
and it's been exquisitely
forged by evolution
to have certain features.
Behaviorally, the big three
are increased risk taking,
increased sensation
seeking, and a move away
from parents to peers.
And I think these are really deeply rooted
in our biology cause it's not just humans.
All social mammals have
these three features.
And so, we're probably
fighting mother nature
by trying to eliminate these.
And this is always very
speculative to argue these ways,
but one idea is that it
helped us get out of the home,
which is a really irrational
thing to do, right?
(audience laughs)
People love us.
They feed us.
They protect us.
It's a good gig, right?
But it turns out it works better if we do.
Less inbreeding, it just
sort of, not morally right
or wrong, it just works
better if this happens.
And so these features,
they evolved at a time
without firearms, without,
you know, high speed
motor vehicles, without
designer drugs and stuff.
Some of these issues are
kind of the stone-age brain
in a computer age world aspect.
But I think that these
behaviors have virtues as well.
When I was I was a the
NIH, the Smithsonian Museum
was sort of close.
They had this exhibit,
The Hall of Human Origins,
which I really like, but kind
of not particularly featured.
A little placard on the floor
looked at the relationship
between brain size and climate change.
And the last big increase in brain size,
500, 800,000 years ago, but
what I thought was intriguing
was that what would correlate
is the change in climate,
not the degree.
So before seeing this, I thought,
yeah, it got really cold.
You had to be super
smart just to stay alive
long enough to get food and reproduce.
But this is subtly different.
Everybody in this room
had ancestors whose brains
were good at adaptation.
And were really good at it in terms of,
even compared to our quite
close, genetically close,
rather in the Neandertrumps
or Neanderthals.
(audience laughs)
I'll pause.
We can edit that later.
(audience applauds)
And there's a, we can tell
an enormous amount from teeth
and fossilized teeth, which
is actually redundant.
Everybody's teeth right now are fossils,
calcified cells, but they work like trees.
So they have rings.
So tree rings you can,
this was a wet year,
a good year of growth,
the rings are wider.
And across many different
species, the rings
get closer and closer as you mature.
The rings stop, and you're
done growing, done maturing.
And so when you find
these fossilized teeth,
if you find a fossilized
Neanderthal tooth of a 12-year-old,
and then check the rest
of the cave, he's gonna be
with his children, not his parents.
And this is often portrayed
as surprisingly rapid growth
in the Neanderthals, but I
think that's the wrong way
to look at it.
What's surprising is
our protracted growth.
We're the outliers by far.
It's one of the most
distinctive things about us.
And even across, like, crows
and many other species,
the longer you're under
protection of your parent,
the more complicated your food gathering,
your communication, you
know, problem solving.
Crows are actually really
smart as an example,
but similar crows in size
and stuff that don't have
this protective maturation
don't have those abilities
as well.
And it doesn't work to
just keep your kids at home
'til they're 40.
I don't think on an individual
basis it doesn't work.
It's an intriguing trade-off I think
that we keep options open.
We keep our brains changeable,
see what the environment's
gonna to be like.
We can live on the North Pole.
We can live on the Equator.
We can even live in outer
space for a little while
with technologies that are
being made and developed.
And so this is a good
thing, I think, in terms
of this ability to keep
options open for a long time,
but it's really being put to the test
with the digital revolution.
And this is just in my short
career, it's a game-changer.
In the way that we interact
and like we're doing
at this moment with ones
and zeros and the lights,
the projectors, you know,
it's changed everything.
It's changed the way that we learn.
You know, content that's on internet.
I mean, the greatest minds on
the planet are a click away,
for free.
It's amazing.
It's magical.
The way that we play, and
the way that we interact
with each other.
And so, I've been fascinated
by this interaction
in terms of the, you know,
biology of this changeability
and the technologies that
have taken over, in a sense,
so of almost 11 hours
a day of screen time.
And 30% of that time more than one device.
And so the usual question
is is it good or bad?
That's the wrong question, right?
Almost any interesting
question is it depends
in terms of in what
ways and how it depends
and what it depends upon.
But I think that this is
an opportunity in terms
of to influence adolescence.
One of the tragedies of my profession
is that it's almost a 10 year gap
between onset of illness and treatment.
It's, we need to do
better, and I think perhaps
new technologies can help
us get there in terms of
by monitoring things like
social media activity.
Maybe even just movement
to best aid harnessing
these technologies in an
ethically appropriate way
to help us recognize mental
illness so that we can
intervene while the brain
is still more changeable.
And so a lot of the debates around this
that it's just not natural, right.
We evolve to talk to each
other, to be with each other,
share smells and touches and everything.
And now, we're looking at screens
for a big part of the day.
But a kind of argument to that is
reading's not natural either.
Reading's only about 5,200 years old.
So most humanity, nobody read.
So I don't think that by
itself is a good argument.
It kind of makes the point that the whole
aspect of this is the changeability.
10,000 years ago, hunting,
gathering berries,
that's the same brain in terms of
that's a blink of an eye
in evolutionary terms.
But our brains are amazing.
We can adapt.
A lot of us spend a lot
of our day with symbols,
you know, words, and that,
and that's so different than, you know,
what our ancestors did.
And so my career has basically been this
in terms of trying to
understand this plasticity
in terms of how to optimize the good
and minimize the bad.
And this, kind of, how do you help people
with mental illness is
the fundamental question.
And so, kind of that
notion of what do we know?
How do we know what we know?
What don't we know?
Why don't we know that?
But, you know, my first assumption
is the brain's involved.
I hope so.
If it's like the spleen or
something, I'm gonna feel
like a complete fool down the road.
But I think, you know, that's
a good reasonable assumption.
And Professor Jernigan began this journey.
BJ and I started together
each following down that path
of looking at the brain
and how the brain changes
in both typical development
and in illnesses.
It's kind of a non-creative
design actually.
But scan kids, you know,
when they're young,
and follow them as they grow through life.
See how they're doing at school, at home.
See what sort of
influences are on the brain
for good or ill.
And at the NH, we did about
10,000 scans, half the kids
healthy, half the kids
with different illnesses.
And what we've found were, it's nuanced,
but like, the brain doesn't mature
by getting bigger and bigger.
By first grade, it's already
93% of an adult size.
It matures by becoming more
connected within itself
and more specialized.
And this idea of being more connected,
there's many ways you can approach this,
but white matter is one of them.
So this insulating material
that you'll get one
to two percent more of in
the fourth or fifth decade.
The brain was able to communicate
amongst itself faster.
It's not very subtle.
It's like a 3,000 fold
increase in bandwidth.
It's, I think, underlies a lot
of the remarkable behaviors
that we can do.
But it's not just a matter
of maximizing speed.
It's all about the timing.
And so fire together, wire
together, the meaning,
all the information in these patterns.
But more and more we're understanding
that's the progression, and
if we look at different parts
of the brain like letters of the alphabet,
as we go from an infant to
child latency, teenagers,
emerging adulthood that
these letters become words,
the words become sentences, the sentences,
you know, paragraphs metaphorically.
And this all goes up in adolescence.
The brain almost, no
matter how you measure it,
whether molecular, EEG,
blood flow, it's just,
you know, it becomes more connected.
And this is a kind of
a fresh look in terms
of this idea of graph theory networks,
and it gives us a whole new look.
So for something like
schizophrenia, before we'd be like,
is this chunk bigger or smaller
or a different shape or size?
But looking at the same
MRI scan and the same data
and looking at how it's interconnected,
then we can discern old from
young, healthy from ill,
cause they bring it back.
Not perfectly, but it's really
exciting for someone like me.
I can't do the math, but
to be a consumer of it
in terms of that, by looking
at this connectivity,
it gives us a whole new
perspective on these illnesses.
The other process is
the gray matter process.
And the one, two punch is
over produce and then war
or fight it out, so it's
how almost all complexity
in nature arises.
Engine of evolution, over
produce something non-random
selection, and it has
great, you know, potential.
So it's constantly ongoing.
It's not like you only over
produce during childhood
and only prune during
adolescence, but we see this
upside down U type of curve
where, as we specialize,
the brain actually becomes smaller.
So after around 10, 11, 12,
your brain doesn't get bigger.
It gets smaller but leaner,
meaner, more specialized
based on what is demanding of it.
But it's not all parts equal.
The prefrontal cortex involved
in controlling impulses,
long-range planning, it's
particularly late to settle down.
Some 25 to 30, and that
combined with the hormonally
activated puberty activated limbic system,
the path of rewards,
this imbalance creates
a lot of the specialness
of teen behavior aspects.
But again, this is how it should be.
If the prefrontal cortex was already done,
like 11 or 12 and stuff, then,
we wouldn't be as adaptable.
And so I think this is the
tension or the trade off.
The other place to start in terms of that,
these illnesses happen at
different times and not perfectly.
There's always variation, but
Alzheimer's doesn't happen
when you're three, and autism
doesn't start when you're 60.
That characteristically,
certain illnesses tend
to emerge at certain ages.
And that's puzzling, you know.
Why is that?
In terms of, and when you
start looking at this,
so much happens in adolescence.
Not a lot, most.
So up to 75%, and I still
don't know the answer.
For 25 years, I've been like, why?
Because the early answer is
oh, teenagers are stressful.
It's stressful time of life.
Kids have their parents
killed in front of them
or a lot are starving to
death in war-torn countries.
Enormous stresses, but they
don't get schizophrenia.
And so that never rang true.
And I still don't know, I
don't know the answer to this.
Why do things happen when they do?
And so just one example
is for schizophrenia.
All of the findings you
see in adult schizophrenia,
you could predict, what
if typical teen changes
went too far?
Is not causal.
They already had schizophrenia.
But it sort of, so far without exception
in terms of both the MRI changes
but also the molecular changes.
And so, it's just, this
point, it's intriguing.
It doesn't help me help
families with schizophrenia.
But I think these are the kinds of clues
that we're starting to understand.
So in the specialization process,
in typical development, it's
about 7% from ages 12 to 17.
In schizophrenia, 28%.
So it's not subtle, you
know, a four fold difference.
And so understanding
the typical development,
I think is key, but about
half of what I deal with
as an illness, isn't an illness, right.
Pregnancy is not an illness.
But it's a big deal, right.
Relationships, car accidents,
incarceration, you know,
life decisions, this
happens during adolescence.
And it's frustrating,
you know, as a physician,
it's like there's no
insurance forms to check
in terms of for these very real issues
that aren't an illness.
And this kind of notion,
is the glass half empty
or half full?
Because this changeability
could be a great opportunity
making it even more tragic
that we aren't recognizing
the illnesses when they occur.
And my final sort of analogy
is to use Michelangelo
in terms of this is a very
famous painting of his
that by design should look like a brain,
a cross-section of the brain.
Yeah, he wrote about it himself and stuff,
and it's sometimes called
the original synapse.
You know?
(audience laughs)
A little neuroscience humor.
But it's not like that.
It's much more like his other
expression of art, sculpting.
And we start with this block
of marble and life experiences.
So then, we eliminate parts.
So me might be born with
different chunks of marble,
from sizes, from genetics,
but within each if we knew
what we were doing, if we
could guide this process,
you know, there's masterpieces.
And, you know, in I
think almost everybody.
And we don't know very, we
don't know what we're doing yet
very well, and it's like, most
of the illnesses emerging,
less than one and a half
percent of the funding
has been adolescence.
Until now, finally, now,
we have this project
that for the first time is
going to really do this right.
11, 12,000 or, you know, kids, 19 sites
across the country to
understand what matters.
How does the brain grow
in health and illness?
Looking at, you know, everything
we can think of frankly,
in terms of, influences on this.
I'm gonna brag for San
Diego a bit in terms of
there's these 19 sites across the country,
but the coordinating center
for the quantitative core
and the neuropsych core
coordinating all the centers
are both here in San Diego as well.
What a good deal for us in
terms of the opportunities
to try to understand, you know,
what matters in teen's lives.
And so the technology is a big part of it.
How can we get a better sense of internal
and external environment with the sensors,
with devices they're already
using, they're already wearing
cause this is the crossroads in right,
this is where people, you
know, make big decisions
about their direction in life.
And there's this kind of notion that teens
are messed up and they're
misguided and stuff,
and it's dangerous.
I feel bad that I've, cause I've...
(audience laughs)
Oh, I see, people, I don't know.
So this is in the crossroads.
And what happens is even teens themselves
buy into this, right.
Like stereotype threat and stuff.
If you think that you're not
capable and stuff like that.
It matters.
Most teens do well.
You know, they'll get through this.
They'll do well.
But I think we do a
disservice by, you know,
selling them short, and
I think that, you know,
we really need to recognize
the huge upsides of this.
Much more than the downsides.
That if we can figure out what
we're doing, what matters,
we can really make a big difference.
Thanks.
(audience applauds)
(light upbeat music)